all right I don't know if any of you
guys are Reading Power Rangers right now
but this comic is amazing and the ending
of this is gonna blow your mind so this
initially opens up with the Power
Rangers showing up to the Moon Flying
the Dragonzord which crash lands into
the moon questions why because there's
basically a giant force field around the
Moon they couldn't get through it
through traditional means so they had to
kind of use like a stealth field
generator but as soon as they went
through the Zord comes crashing down but
once they get there goldar is like
racing towards them with an army of
putties now their initial response here
is like okay well here comes goldar
leading an army of putties like he
always does but nah man it's goldar
fleeing for his life this dude's running
as fast as he possibly can and even when
he gets there he's like you guys have to
help me right now the reason why they're
even here is because they're responding
to a distress signal and this distress
signal was sent by Lord Zed himself so
for those of the guys who never follow
the Power Rangers lore Zed was a horse
right this guy was like the original OG
like straight up villain in the Power
Rangers Mythos so the fact that this guy
is calling for help is kind of a crazy
thing so in response of course the Power
Rangers show up and they do what they
can where they can but they're basically
told that Lord that himself is in a
chamber right in the caves below the
surface of the Moon and under the palace
and so you end up getting like Tommy the
White Ranger Kimberly the Pink Ranger
and then Matt the Green Ranger who
respond Now Matt will talk about here in
a little bit because he is a ranger but
he's not technically a Zordon Power
Ranger he actually got his powers from a
woman named Grace and a company called
Promethea which was kind of cool right
it was a really cool concept but as soon
as they get there basically Lord Zed
just kind of calls out for help and Rita
repulsa is like standing over this guy
now Technically she's not Rita she's
mistress vile we'll explain that too
because she's pretty awesome in this
form but the funny thing here is that
like the Power Rangers do exactly what
you would expect them to do right like
they go to fight Rita repulsa and this
mystery man that she has by her side
who's simply known as the vessel that
guy is amazing dude this guy is so dope
in fact in this fight this guy makes a
move against like Matt the Green Ranger
and just like smashes his head into a
wall like that one of the things to
understand the Power Rangers are pretty
capable right these guys are able to
hold their own against most any and all
threats not against the vessel man this
guy dominates every one of these folks
and it's not even by a little bit right
Kimberly is being held captive by Rita
repulsely because that's Kimberly and
she sucks but when it comes to like
Tommy the White Ranger this guy's
getting absolutely crushed and even Lord
Zed tells him no do not fight them if
you fight them you will die Retreat is
the only thing that we can do so
basically that's all they have right
like Matt just throws Lords out on his
back Tom he's like get out of here guys
teleport out get back to headquarters
and like we'll call it a day the problem
is they can't really repair the original
dragon sword that they used to get to
the surface so they end up having to use
serpenterra what serpenterra that's
basically the Dragonzord provided to
Matt by way of Grace and like promethia
it's like the second generation dragon
sword and I gotta be honest with you
guys man this one's kind of better than
the first if I'm being honest it just
looks cooler but for Tommy himself right
the White Ranger who's nowhere near as
cool as he was when he was originally
the Green Ranger I don't care what
anybody says Tommy the Green Ranger is
better than Tommy when he was a white
ranger and there's no arguing that point
but this dude gets crushed by The Vessel
I mean he like pins the sky against the
wall smashes heading to the ground it's
not even a fight right it's not even
like a contest like come to find out
Matt had basically shown back up again
and now Matt is in effect sacrifice
fighting himself in order to give Tommy
and Kimberly a way out of here now what
he does here is he kind of refers to
himself using words like you know he's
the extra he's the unnecessary guy that
kind of thing and to a degree he is but
he's also not at the same time and again
we'll kind of clarify all that here in a
second right refrain to himself as the
spare and so on and so forth but where
the Power Rangers grab serpenterra and
get out as fast as they can you end up
having the vessel and you have Rita I.E
mistress vile that use the combination
of their staffs although technically the
vessel is using the staff of Lord Zed to
basically shoot the thing down right so
they get out just far enough to be able
to teleport away and that's essentially
it but Matt is basically just left back
there and effectively trapped only for
us to find out that what reader will
pulse is doing here she has basically
arrived in this place for the purpose of
stealing the Zeo Crystal now this is
where you start to run into some of the
similarities but also some of the
differences between the original Power
Rangers series and the comic book and
what I mean is like the comic originally
started out sort of filling in the gaps
between the different episodes of the
original Power Rangers series but kind
of became its own Mythos right so for
those of you guys who remember season
three Master vial and the metallic armor
the whole idea behind that is that below
the surface of the Moon is the Zeo
Crystal which basically contains a vast
amount of power a person who's able to
contain this would be nigh Unstoppable
we'll find out exactly what Rita's plan
is when it comes to all this but once
Zed is taken back to the headquarters of
the Power Rangers he basically reveals
to Zordon exactly what had gone down and
seemingly just like out of nowhere Rita
just like showed up with the vessel and
this Army of putties that were basically
indestructible and just took the place
over right just like that launched like
this crazy attack against everybody and
even against the power of the vessel
Lord Zed was basically nothing right
there was nothing he could do against
this guy and that's why he told the
Power Rangers you have to get out of
here because if you don't you're all
gonna die but getting the Zeo crystal is
no small thing because then they start
to realize exactly how powerful that
she's become as well as what it is that
she's capable of and presumably what it
is that she's going to be doing but what
you end up doing in the middle of all of
this is the Rangers are basically
distracted because they're sent on a
mission by Zordon to basically respond
to the Omega Rangers who have
effectively sent out a kind of SOS now
the Omega Rangers are unique to the
comic book line they are not in the TV
series and I don't think they've ever
been in the TV series in any capacity
suffice it to say they're pretty
powerful a lot of the traditional Power
Rangers that you're aware of Jason Zach
Trini they went on to become Omega
Ranger that's how the comics sort of
split the difference between like the OG
Power Rangers and like the newer version
of the Power Rangers like Rocky and
Aisha and different characters like that
Alpha One is basically just a robot
right that reader repulsa has the
earliest iteration of alpha 5 right the
robot that kind of helps out Zordon and
so forth that was basically corrupted
and the way this is explained is that
Rita in talking to Matt who she's
currently torturing and tormenting and
so on she talks about how for her being
the daughter of mistress vile she never
really had any respect for her father
and the reason for this is he was always
on the hunt for basically the Zeo
Crystal right this artifact that could
be used in order to create a vessel for
the dark Specter now the dark Specter is
just kind of like this nigh omnipotent
being that exists out there and in fact
we'll get more information about him
here in a little while but the overall
gist here is that for eons Untold right
that Master vile has constantly been
seeking out some kind of a vessel for
the dark Specter presenting that vessel
but it just never really seems to reach
fruition because he's always missing
what is in effect the Zeo Crystal he can
never get his hands on it so that's why
Rita never really takes him seriously
and even he himself is kind of a failure
because of all the power that Master
vile has all comes by way of the dark
Specter at any moment he can take that
power away and in fact that's exactly
what goes on here that what they do is
they go to the planet and furnace the
home of where the dark Specter currently
resides with its existing host and
master vile presents the new host which
turned out to be Alpha 1 in this
particular circumstance right that Alpha
One was kind of recreated or at least
reprogrammed by Master vile in order to
send him forward as a potential host the
issue here is that when he's presented
as a vessel for the dark Specter the
dude flips he's like really a robot
right like a walking talking metal
machine with wires that's your tribute
that's your offering and he tells them
like for too long have I granted you
Untold power and watched you fail for
too long have I made excuses for the
fact that you're never able to come
through and what he does intend to kill
him instead Rita turns on him and in
fact she attacks her dad on the spot and
even goes to try to kill him and for the
most part she actually holds off she
simply decides not to destroy him and
that's kind of the question that alpha
one asked like why don't you simply
destroy him but what you end up getting
here is the dark Specter who looks to
her and says one because of the fact
that you have a smidge right you're
infused with Morphin grid energy then
there's no way for me to basically take
over you right because the dark Specter
cannot actually access the morphin grit
this source of power for all the Power
Rangers read us not technically a Power
Ranger but she does have a bit of the
morphin grid about her and so what she
says is yes I know that I cannot be your
host but I can be your new violent this
is how it was that Rita achieved this
immense level of power and immediately
took out Lord Zed and all of his forces
because from there it was her on the
hunt to find the zero Crystal now now as
for the vessel this was just kind of
found on a frozen World there is more to
this if you know please do not spoil in
the comments section but what we do is
we jump away from this flashback with
Rita repulsa gaining our new power
Master vial and so on and we pick up
with the fight with Alpha One and this
guy is able to pretty much overpower all
the Rangers who are here the only reason
he's able to do this though is because
of the level of power that was given to
him by Rita by way of her mistress vile
Powers right the abilities and the
enhancements that came along with that
if this was just like the normal Alpha
One yeah this guy would have just been
beat to a pulp they would have turned
this guy into a toaster and they all
would have been eating breakfast right
that's all it really would have been but
what ends up going on here is Trini of
the Omega Rangers pops up and what she
says is that Alpha One had actually deep
powered and defeated pretty much all of
the Omega Rangers except for her and
another guy so that's why the forces
here are very limited they are able to
offer a conflict here a measure of
resistance and they do cut the head off
of Alpha One and turn himself into a
giant machine which is pretty cool right
it's pretty awesome to see him walk
around with his head cut off but then
you'll get a bit of information from
Trini at least what little information
she's able to provide directly to
Kimberly and all she really says here is
that this planet used to have what was
called a Master Forge well actually
learn that's something referred to as an
arc which really has a significant role
in all of this and really kind of pieces
together what it is that Rita is doing
but presumably that's why Alpha One was
here but again everything popped off
with the Omega Rangers and the Power
Rangers before they can even really get
a definitive answer and even when Alpha
One his head is just talking to them and
kind of taunting them with like I'll
eventually reconstruct myself I cannot
be killed I'm basically Immortal he
doesn't really give them a whole lot of
information right he just says like I am
in the service of Rita and I will help
her achieve her goal of allowing the
dark Specter to enter the universe and
Conquer everything right so just
traditional villain stuff but what they
are able to do do is attain what's
called a Morphin grid Navigator what is
this okay so this is explained to us
within the confines of this story and
what we're told here is that eons ago
the morphin Masters basically the ones
who created the morphin grid and are
responsible for just the nature of the
power source that Power Rangers tap into
to attain their abilities that they
built Master arches on several planets
rich in connection to the morphin grid
the best way to think about the morphin
grid within the Power Rangers Mythos is
to give it like the force from Star Wars
it kind of permeates everything but it's
almost similar to like the speed force
in DC Comics where it is like an actual
realm slash Dimension that exists out
there so again it's a pretty cool
concept but they're told that an evil
entity known as dark Specter was
determined to access the main world
right the real world through these
portals and sent numerous invasions to
these various planets the results were
catastrophic and so faced with the fact
that dark Specter could potentially
really enter in from his Dimension to
the real world and bring seemingly
Untold death and destruction along with
it the morphin Masters did the only
thing they could they basically
destroyed these arches so that there was
no conceivable way for the dark Specter
to enter into the real world hence the
necessity of a vessel that if a person
can serve as what is in effect a
physical host for the essence of dark
Specter he can enter into the main World
itself and effectively reactivate these
portals and then do his own thing such
as it is that's the goal of Rita in his
stead the goal of Rita is to find these
arches activate them and then give this
guy a literal doorway that he could use
to enter into this place now as far as
the Navigator is concerned it's one of
the coolest things because what we're
told here is that with Navigators
themselves you can effectively use them
to enter into the morphin grid and when
you do they're really just kind of like
a beacon or like a compass you can
travel anywhere in time and space face
the past the present the future all
throughout the entirety of the dimension
the other part of this is that seemingly
the morphin grid has access to any and
other alternate realities that exists
out there we're not told that directly
but that seems to be the case but
regardless of how you slice it by way of
Rita repulsa having this Navigator and
then being able to enter the morphin
grid due to the fact that she is
partially infused with Morphin energy
yes it could allow dark Specter to enter
into the real world but it would allow
her to enter into the morphin grid and
then travel at any point through the
past in the present imagine if Rita
could go back and simply just stop the
Power Rangers from ever being created in
the first place now what you end up
getting following this is you have a
meeting that takes place between Lord
Zed and a woman named Grace now this is
where we kind of start to talk about the
character of Matt because within the
Power Rangers Mythos Grace is a woman
that leads an organization called
Promethea they're like a multi-billion
dollar our company that's out there
what's also ironic is she was at one
point a red ranger but the thing about
this is that prometheia while it is his
own organization it works alongside the
Power Rangers and it actually has access
to things like the morphin grid and so
on and so forth that's how Matt got his
powers he's basically a green ranger
that was effectively created by Grace
right the dragon sword that he has is by
all Sanders a measurement gifted to him
by way of Grace it's a cool thing right
that's why he kind of refers to himself
as like the spare or the extra or the
unnecessary guy because he wasn't really
given a Morpher by Zordon himself now as
for Lord Zed while he talks to Grace and
she keeps talking about how like we'll
find a way to win and that kind of thing
he almost kind of mocks her and makes
fun of her you know because he's like
you humans even in the face of complete
and total eradication you're still
hopeful you still believe that you
actually have a chance but he
effectively tells her I'm the only one
that can help you I'm the only one that
can ensure that any and all of you you
are able to come out on top if I am not
free from this prison and if I am not
able to achieve my goal of destroying
Rita and taking the Zeo Crystal from her
then yeah everything is going to end you
guys can do what you can when you can
where you can but nothing's going to
come out of that and so what you end up
doing here and this is like the most
epic part of this whole story you guys
are gonna lose your minds what you end
up doing here is you pick up with zed
while he's in his prison and there's
this guy that walks by and kind of like
taunts him and makes fun of him right
talks trash to him a little bit and Zed
is just kind of like you really think
that this this archaic force field could
truly hold me has it ever occurred to
you that I'm here because I choose to be
not because I have to be and this guy
doesn't necessarily even really seem to
understand what it is that Zed sang
right he says like I think you're
talking real big for a guy without his
magic staff it'll still hurt trying to
get through this quote-unquote archaic
Force field and his response is you
think I fear pain I have been flayed
alive human I have experienced pain more
severe than anything you could ever
comprehend sticking my hand through a
force field and the shock that comes
with it that's nothing right something
like overpowers this guy and just walks
right through the force field right now
here's the crazy thing at that point
alarm Bells go off everywhere right like
everybody's freaking out everybody's
panicking Lord Zeds escaped right there
like like literally Grace is just like
oh my God that's Lord Zed sector when
they get there she says what are you
holding and he says a present originally
left as a special surprise for the
Rangers but refashioned for a different
purpose I believe there is a special
term that's used when one of these is
activated let me think oh that's right I
remember now It's morphin time that's
right ladies and gentlemen Lord Zed has
just become a Power Ranger what that
being said guys
work for watching and I will catch you
all later peace